I self-centered colleagues narcissistic manipulator liar without empathy or remorse
and with 1 pathological need for power and control This is Pedro Sanchez.
Pedro,
who for years has defended in Spain that the
amnesty law would be unconstitutional,
has decided to stay in power and get the vote of 7 separatist deputies to
approve an unconstitutional amnesty law that constitutes 1 blow to the separation
of powers and therefore to the rule of law.
Sedition embezzlement public disorder attack tax fraud money laundering
disobedience injuries and terrorism are just some of the crimes committed
by separatists who will not be able to stand trial.